one of the things i loved about
spiderman no way home was that they were
actual supporting characters yes exactly
versus just fun cameos that's why i'm
like it's hard to believe a lot of this
but a lot of us just want to speculate
on absolutely i'm rooting for terence
howard to show up as iron man
what's happening there reject nation
greg and john here today no this is not
a re-upload if you caught our video from
a couple weeks ago this is a reshoot
there was a copyright issue with the
last video and rather than just keeping
that video up that took a few hours to
put together uh we're like just screw it
let's just reshoot it you know you can't
do that with a reaction because it's a
reaction but i was like no we could we
have the power to reshoot this and avoid
that copyright issue now most
importantly and if you did happen to
catch the last one stick around because
uh we're gonna add a little bit more to
this one as opposed to that other one
and we're gonna make it even better than
that one it's gonna be even more
efficient than that last one and what
are we talking about today guys dr
strange ii multiverse of madness cameos
that have been rumored speculated upon
and just cameos in general that we
personally want to see ourselves and you
know what guys let's just dive right
into it yet beautiful bastards so the
first thing i want to talk about is
something that i think has been rumored
uh ever since actually the announcement
of disney plus secret invasion show
because i let a lot of people are
thinking oh my god does this mean secret
wars is on the brink of actually
happening and now with spider-man no way
home out which really solidified the
multiverse being a very real thing along
with the loki series a lot of people
have been really hoping for
secret wars which if you guys don't know
what that comic is it's basically just a
big collision
of all kinds of marvel glory in one from
the multiverse and with that people have
been really speculating about the
illuminati possibly showing up here in
dr strange multiverse and madness now if
you guys don't know who the illuminati
are they're a very important group in
the marvel comics comprised of different
leaders from several different groups to
protect earth they usually consist of
namor black bolt iron man or reed
richards and dr strange and so the hope
that some people have been having is
that if the illuminati are featured in
this movie that they could perhaps be
like a multiverse gathering you know so
instead of being one dedicated to
protect earth that they would protect
the multiverse and if you've seen wanda
vision it seems likely based off that
post-credit scene with wanda and the
darkhold that she might end up being not
an ally to doctor strange as he hopes in
the trailer but perhaps an actual
villain which i think would be cool
really see wanda maximuff unleash that
scarlet witch so with that in mind a
cameo or maybe a supporting character
that has been rumored to be in this
since the days of wanda vision how even
one division came out paul bettany was
saying there's a special cameo that's
going to appear and then we all found
out paul benny was just trolling i was
heavily theorizing and i'm still
sticking to this theory but now just
applying it to doctor strange multiverse
amanda that it's actually going to be
patrick stewart as uh professor x i
think professor x could be in here it
could be a new professor x maybe it
could be james mcavoy we're hearing this
movie could possibly be really inspired
from the house of m which dealt with
similar plot points that we've seen set
up from wanda vision wanda wanting to
maintain having her children creating a
new universe in that comics where her
children can exist a lot of timelines
are being rewritten and such but the
main person they use to help keep her in
check or they or their hope to keep her
in check is professor xavier so i feel
like introducing professor x especially
now the fox merger is complete i think
this would be a great movie to introduce
him in yeah and i mean if the potential
of the illuminati also holds true i mean
especially with cerebro i could
definitely imagine him piercing through
the multiversal void and maybe bringing
that whole team together you know and if
he isn't here a hope of mine would be
that he has the uh levitating
yellow chair make it more comics
accurate that would be my main hope and
of course you know with this being
multiverse of madness one of the first
things that i heard fans like really
hope for
right when this movie was announced was
getting hugh jackman back as wolverine
to make a cameo now generally i've been
on the side of he said goodbye to that
character we don't really need him to be
in here and i don't want them to rewrite
anything but it's hugh jackman you know
and as much as i want there to be a new
wolverine for the marvel cinematic
universe obviously they will eventually
do that hugh jackman has been on record
many times saying how he's wanted to
collab with the avengers how is
wolverine be included in the marvel
cinematic universe so just to give him
that that extra little cherry of
acknowledgement if they do throw him in
here i'd actually be satisfied i've gone
back on that and so i don't actually
think he'll be in here
but i would like him to be i'll say that
yeah when i think of all the places for
him to pop up this would be a prime
place for him to make an appearance in
the mcu everyone cheers and then we can
move on yeah exactly and then another
one part of the x-men list uh there's
two more one is just a wish that i
really have which would be ian mckellen
specifically you know like michael
fossbender would be cool but i would i
would root for ian mckellen to show up
as magneto here because you know one
division had a lot of fun with bringing
us evan peters as a ralph boner but the
whole point of the fun was that he's
playing quicksilver that's at least what
we were thinking he was doing in that
movie quicksilver in the fox universe
his dad is magneto which lines up with
the comics of house of m
so if there was like a variant of wanda
that you do see or she's hopping through
another universe where like her family
her parents are alive but her parents
are not who they are in the mcu it would
actually be like her dad is magneto that
would be a great way to bring back ian
mckellen oh yeah like one last buy
because you didn't really get to have
that true and i mean you know as great
as michael fossbender as i think if they
were to do that ian mckellen has that
paternal presence true to him true yeah
absolutely and then with like what we
were just talking about quicksilver as
we saw in one division she was really
mourning the loss of her brother pietro
as much as she's looking for like her
own children as set up by the events of
one division maybe she can hop through
the multiverse looking for quicksilver
to exist and then we'll get a ralph
boner joke yeah acknowledging fan
outrages
yeah i'm sure by this point too you guys
have heard this rumor it's been going on
for years i think and the man the actor
himself has even commentated on it
saying he's heard of the rumors
regarding him and how he hasn't gotten a
call from marvel and he's not the
werewolf he's not the werewolf either
but he did say he would love to do it
and you know the big rumors about john
krasinski as mr fantastic popping up in
this movie these rumors are just as
strong as they were when people thought
he was going to pop up in one division
we didn't learn our lessons yeah
obviously the fantastic four is already
announced john watts is working hard on
that film right now and maybe they
already have a cast assembled like if we
did get a mr fantastic or reed richards
in this film maybe it could be john
krasinski which would be cool like oh we
this is our introduction of the new mr
fantastic but you know after spider-man
no way home which did have that
nostalgia blend and if they are doing
that thing where hey now that we have
the fox universe we're lining all these
multiverses called multiverse of madness
i would want it to be
yo how do you say his name johan
griffith gosh he really should spell the
difference
here that well she's screwing everybody
up the original guy to play mr fantastic
from the tim story films
personally i know everyone's really
opting for john krasinski we don't even
know if mr fantastic will be in here but
if any of these rumors did happen to
come true i would love it to be young
rufford i think it would be nice to
validate that and i think too it would
be less distracting like if you brought
in krazynski i feel like that's a
post-credit scene move and then this is
one that i think fans have been just
demanding everywhere online i haven't
even seen a real rumor about it it's
really just been a major demand that i
think a lot of fans have been
petitioning for which i personally after
hearing it went that would be the [ __ ]
chris evans as the human torch as you
got freeway yeah as you guys know chris
evans was the human torch in the tim
story fantastic four movies and i think
that would just lend so much more
credence to the whole variant identity
thing that they've been doing within the
marvel cinematic universe and it would
be such a cool way for chris edmonds to
return to the mcu without returning to
the mcu yeah and to create humor without
making a cheap joke out of it yes you
could totally have doctor strange be
like wait a minute why do i recognize
you why do you look like steve rogers
yeah yeah yeah that would be really fun
i mean i personally would love to see
that i mean would you guys want to see
that please that would be awesome
another one that i have written down
here is sue storm which makes sense you
know considering that we're talking
about the fantastic four if you have mr
fantastic in here his relationship
associated with his just at least have
zeus still nobody else yeah it could be
jessica albo which would be neat there's
been a lot more support for her over the
years that's the way it goes you know
justice for jessica justice for jessica
like knowledge the greatness of jessica
film performance it would be cool to see
uh sue's storm pop up in here because i
think as much as those films weren't
exactly loved they were important to a
certain extent and sticking with the
whole x-men characters on this roster
right now when i first heard you know
like fans asking for this i i don't know
about that but i i guess i could i could
see it he is in the mcu now officially
kevin feige has talked directly they are
going to be doing the follow-up to this
film and it will be r-rated
ryan reynolds is deadpool we are doing
multiverse of madness i've always said
that if we are going to connect the
universes i kind of feel like deadpool
would be one of the best gateways to
doing that he's the leader of the
illuminati yeah
dr train just shows up it's just
deadpool yeah i'm just busting his balls
the whole time well i do think that
deadpool because of his meta nature can
make the commentary on all this to make
the connective threads even better yeah
you know because at this point with all
the there's so many rumor cameos that
i'm like man most of these cannot be
real if any
yeah yeah they have to be like blink and
you'll miss it flashes or something they
won't be like character characters but
when you know when you're talking about
deadpool like i could see a possibility
of deadpool actually showing up in here
well yeah and think of how fun it would
be to see that character under sam
raimi's direction too because you could
get some real army of darkness kind of
shiny vibes out of that and then
sticking within this fox universe one
that i've seen a lot of fans asking for
especially after charlie cox appeared in
spider-man no way home spoiler alert
sorry about that ben affleck as
daredevil and i think it's due to the
fact that the daredevil director's cut
has gone on a lot of praise even for
people who don't like that movie people
have been like but ben affleck's
actually good in that film he's had some
negative association with his portrayal
as daredevil so this could just be a fun
thing to do for him same time i don't
believe he'll show up in here i really
feel like this guy just wants to step
away from all this yeah i i almost feel
like it would take like a really juicy
role for him to actually take on in like
a decade yeah for him to come into a
place like the mcu yeah and then hearing
about speculation and rumors with
variants of mcu characters now this list
is forever all right like you can
literally extrapolate all characterized
the amount of people i see on social
media just talking about this i hear
this uh oh maybe this or i would love to
see this like the list just goes on and
on i'm only gonna stick to a few that i
i think would be like the most fun the
ones that i personally would want to see
obviously none of this is confirmed um
but you know like
a popular one that's been going around
for ages because of the fact that we're
dealing with multiverse of madness this
guy was originally the one sought ad to
play the title role the head of the
marvel cinematic universe tom cruise as
iron man there's been fan art of this
guy for ages
so if we are gonna get various i doubt
robert downey jr would uh come back for
this it really seems like he wants to
you know say goodbye leave his peace
with this yeah tom cruise is iron man
here's the honest to god truth
i don't think he's in it i don't believe
he'd do it for some reason i just feel
like he he wouldn't
however i would love to be wrong
i would love to be wrong maybe it'll be
a less grossman moment where he really
wants to do it yeah that would be very
gratifying i think you'd be a blast yeah
i think it'd be a blast and another one
with original casting uh that you know
when we're speaking of john krasinski
his wife emily blunt who was originally
sought to play black widow maybe she
could show up as black widow in this
movie as well that could be cool the
reason why i have a hard time believing
this because i know we're going to do a
lot of multiverse hopping [ __ ] like
are these cameos going to be substantial
whatsoever if there are a gazillion
cameos because i like a couple can be
one of the things i loved about
spiderman no way home was that they were
actual supporting characters yes exactly
versus just fun cameos that's why i'm
like it's hard to believe a lot of this
but a lot of us just want to speculate
on absolutely i'm rooting for terence
howard to show up as iron man yes yes
that would be very cool absolutely it
would be cool and it would bury a
long-standing hatchet i mean that would
get people cheering i think i mean then
frick bring back like edward north bring
back
and i feel like actually that could work
better because i feel like there's a
little bit more sort of latent love for
that movie but wouldn't it ruin
canonically the whole thing with the
incredible hulk i think he is
because that movie is still considered
yeah yeah yeah exactly to bring up eric
benner yes that would be neat there we
go show up because you look at one movie
yeah and it wasn't the same situation as
like all the things that edward norton
has talked publicly about of having his
disagreements with marvel it's just that
woman eric banner didn't pan out well
but i thought it was good yeah they were
still figuring out the genre at that
point yes ever since the days of
spider-man we're always hearing rumors
of spider-man popping up here all of
them it would be cool if you think about
it because of the fact that doctor
strange was in a multiverse spider-man
movie it would reason to stand that one
of the spider-man could possibly appear
it's like tom holland wouldn't be a
surprise none at all i think andrew
garfield is one that has been the most
beloved and the most talked about since
that movie that's they've done a reshoot
probably already but if spider-man were
to show up in here my personal desire
would be because of the fact that our
director is sam raimi that it would be
toby maguire to show up in here oh yeah
like if they could get toby to come back
for this that could be more satisfying
for me in some ways more than spider-man
no way home because he's reunited with
the director oh yeah and what if he were
to show up with the person who has the
doctor strange name in the sam raimi
spider-man universe oh yeah another
strange variant pay off that easter egg
from 20 years ago i've been ready to go
that's dr schroeder that's dr street
yeah that's pretty good
but it's taken so one thing that i've i
saw uh from comicbook.com like ages ago
a rumor about like loki sylvie and
mobius showing up here which i think
would make a lot of sense because of the
fact that you know the loki series dealt
with the multiverse that ending of loki
which showed that the multiverse was
going into chaos one of these movies
would finally know
so i think them showing up would make a
lot of sense another group that has been
often speculated about finally appearing
this has been a group that i've been
hearing about for years now at this
point wanting them to appear and looking
at doctor strange multiverse and madness
going down a darker path would be the
midnight suns bring out that horror as
much as i've heard the midnight sun's
talked about for ages introducing
qualities of them in here would make a
lot of sense because this is a
supernatural horror it's like we've been
hearing talks of like i've been hearing
about this guy forever ghost writer you
know this nick cage version has been the
agents of shield version and now there's
rumors about them looking for a new
ghost writer i actually think if they
brought ghost rider in i would love for
them to keep robbie reyes from agency
because he was supposed to have his own
hulu show and then that guy can and i'm
like that poor son of a [ __ ]
such a good job
let him have it yeah at least let him
get a fist pump moment in the movie and
that would make up for it for everybody
that'd be my desire yeah and then of
course you know as we heard mahershal
lee has been cast as blade he was in the
post-credits scene for eternals so you
know the one wish that fans have been
having is for blade to pop up in this
movie and if blade did show up i think
it would line up really well it'd be a
cool way to tease him like i've been
thinking that blake could show up in
moon nights oh yeah and if blade is like
making these little appearances before
he gets his official movie that'd be a
great way of reintroducing him yeah plus
we could have ryan reynolds make a blade
three joke if debbie were poor to be in
the movie too
perfect and then another character that
who's confirmed to be in the the
marvel's movie monica rambo is another
character that i is based off of her
power set i could definitely see her
popping up in here and considering
yeah especially being in wanda vision
you know because the trailer does say
i'm not here about west view but i'm
having a feeling those of west view
incidents are gonna really factor in
thinking about monica rambo possibly
would make a lot of sense and actually
this next one
i've been thinking that she would appear
in here because of the fact that in the
doctor strange trailers you do see what
looks like schumacher some people have
been thinking that it could be a
gargantos
the tentacle monster
hp lovecraftian figure yes yes whatever
that character is obviously was in the
what if series so in this trailer we saw
what i believe to be strange supreme
some are arguing that it might not be
him i think it is and that creature was
first teased in the captain carter
episode of what if
and after the events of what if it would
make a lot of sense for me to get a
captain carter to appear in this video
yeah absolutely and i mean you know
we've seen doctor strange obviously
recruiting other people's help
throughout the trailer and if they are
going to actually start tying in the
events of what if i think that could
actually be really cool and it could
help that episode kind of appreciate in
value for people i think this is kind of
just an obvious one obviously it's not
confirmed
but of all the characters to possibly
show up yeah like i haven't even really
seen rumors about this to be the only
prank with you
just i kind of just assumed because you
hear their voices at the end of one
division tommy and billy wicken in speed
perhaps it might be a grown-up version
people have been wanting the young
avengers to finally happen we got kate
bishop in the fold now so tommy and
billy being part of young avengers would
make a lot of sense so yeah i think
tommy and billy could be in here but
yeah guys this is like the main ones
that really uh stood out to me look i'm
telling you the list goes like on and on
and on and we there's the ones that we
just wanted to highlight
ourselves but guys who would you want
most to appear in doctor strange
multiverse madness or anyone that we
didn't mention that you're like no it
would be cool if they feature them
though put it down below in the comics
thanks so much for being here and uh
hopefully we don't run into any issues
with this one
we'll see you guys